hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Hector we don't have
a lot of time actually we have a lot of
time at the beginning of the episode so
we don't really need to worry about that
okay I lied I'm starting this episode
off with a whole lie
these look like animal cages great am i
any animal I am NOT an animal I am a man
hmm sounds like what else do we have
there gonna be another monster around
here laughing right well there doesn't
seem doesn't seem to be anything over
there
so I guess my choice is limited this
isn't quite the Stanley parable right
right right right
blam ow my face okay cool
that sounds great I'm glad we're talking
about recipes and we got over the whole
nightmare part left right left I see I
messed up I'm such a doof click I'm a
genius Yeah right
oh no I messed up what's my punishment
anymore I'm an animal I got good stuff
then so now that I got 25 pills I guess
I'll be settled for the near future
that'll last me like one episode great
this is weird I have no idea what's
going on right now then again that's
pretty much my assumption for the
majority of this game so I don't think
that actually changes anything
only if one such monster of diabolical
nature was to come out of
left and right okay bye
right do I wanna I want to go left
I like left left is good that's real
good okay good I consumed many pills
however there's probably some bonus for
back that was that did somebody break
some over here hmm
someone better not be messing up this
testing facility that's kind of like
orbital I bet this is like some test to
see if if like the illusion of choice
isn't actually there they probably lead
to the same location all right then it's
like these pills are the the the process
that I'm undergoing the brainwashing
that they're talking about is like run
[ __ ] CEO tell me to run [ __ ] I tell
myself to run [ __ ] I don't need you to
tell me to run [ __ ] rats okay it okay
so I went by the scenes it's very portal
to ask but I mean I bet the brainwashing
is like it removes the option from your
mind so you think it's a choice you
think they're controlling you but you
don't have anything else to do very
interesting very intriguing I don't
think I put my words together quite
right there but hopefully it made sense
one blob blob blob good enough more
pills
am I good I'm gonna gonna be healthy I
need my benzo I love muffins Oh am I
missing anything you you're right okay
am I getting close to where I started
the beginning of the game with a whole
you know my spleen getting ripped open
and something sewn back up probably
something sewn back up into me that's
another story
bye see that's this story but it's just
a story for later what else is gonna
happen to me
but I'm ready right so it seemed to be
looping around I don't know if there are
collectibles around here that I'm
supposed to get but all the doors are
locked
are you offering me what do you want
from me okay well I don't ever can't
open this door
Hey look Jess
we need more pieces were gonna play I
have a king oh I get it I need to find
the king
oh no I didn't find that did I not find
the chess piece in the velvet area oh no
did I screw up oh no oh no
let me I have the chess be seen I got
another no I missed my old nurse I miss
my old nurse she was incredibly fat and
so I wanted her to be fatter still so I
baked delicious tarts each week just to
see the crumbs fall into all the rolls
and cracks I wondered how long they
would stay there well I got my first
note from the doctor I'm so honored to
hear your ramblings wait so I - is not
gonna put that in there he's in another
room I should
okay there's something to come after me
I better keep moving but I gotta check
this note oh he and I got to go on a
trip upstairs today the doctor gave the
two of us a gun and I got to hold it he
said we were going to play a game I like
aims upstairs there was a man named
Jackson Jackson was it the doctor said
we had to go upstairs and use the gun on
Jackson and then he wouldn't be it
anymore I was a little jealous of
Jackson I wanted to be it maybe next
time the doctor told me that I should
try not to feel jealous about what other
people have he says that we all get what
we are owed in the end maybe Jackson
will play with me again when it's my
turn to be it I don't think Jackson's
gonna be playing with anybody a little
Missy I don't like that I don't like
that at all there's nothing else in this
room do I have to go back to that thing
whatever that may be
hey hey friend my brain melted take some
pills I guess that make it all better
my brainless melty
probably sound another one why do i how
do I need to oh good I'm back out here
so I'm assuming that the game just
randomly generates until I find the set
piece that it wants me to find let's
just like a secret tucked away somewhere
for the most part I think I'm on my own
oh Sh gangbusters okay goodbye
Boosh gangbusters okay got an oh god the
new subject has tested better than
expected he tolerates pain because he
does not take care to notice how much we
hurt him perhaps he died long ago before
he was ever truly reborn that doesn't
make any sense if you think about the
words that you're saying they don't make
any sense at all doc maybe you want to
reevaluate your life choices not be
totally murdering um gang Buster boom
boom boom okay that one don't open okay
mr. music man if you could calm your
orchestra down
I took maybe picked that Orchestra
because it kinda has needed Oh got a
battery Oh something is happening oh hey
I'm gonna go this way really quickly
alright yeah I don't know what the hell
that monster is supposed to be but it's
not very smart it's very stupid whereas
I am very intelligent and in it I don't
know if I'm supposed to fight whereas it
is a big dumb dummy dumb couldn't find
me if I was right in front of its face
which I probably will be versa Hey look
wait I saw glowy there
no no no stop the water starts the fire
the man who's eight now is at eleven
eighty Washburn Hill that's a long name
to remember but the doctor says we will
say it every danger here routine and
soon it will be easy stop the water
start the fire up to the fourth floor we
go we get to ride the elevator we had to
ride it all the way up to the fourth
floor but the doctor says we only get to
go for the elevator ride if you've
stopped the water stop the water start
the fire okay this little girl is not
being brainwashed to good things she
being brainwashed bad things Oh what
else what fresh hell have you prepared
for me no no benzo it's a screaming
screamer okay so where am I gonna go
the dancing friendly face who's gluing
peanut I want to hang it up so let me
paint up okay fine abandoning I tried my
best
I got a chest piece well that's black
inky blackness
okay then that's uh yeah that didn't
harm me at all what's the point of that
I was there
don't touch me with your is eNOS all
right gangbusters
BAM another piece didn't have a king or
oh I already put the king down any of
the Queen now damn it I was just gonna
have to go out there over and over again
and to find these pieces if he takes
like King I will give back is gold only
time will tell
yeah there's a dancer I'm a doctor
I don't best I'm gonna do all good for
these patients
okay now go back down everything's gonna
be different I'm gonna go this way
wait that knot that's the way I came
from I need to go this way ah there we
go
now everything's better and by better I
mean different how by different I mean
douchey very douchey and collectible no
it's all seems very familiar almost as
if I parent here before well that's
different
what do we got come this way before I
can't remember how many times have I
said that explain its order
again an orchestra man I can't
differentiate you from the sounds that
I'm not supposed to be hearing okay I
just win a big circle I think I probably
need to stop sprinting so much because I
seem to slow down and probably need to
save that for when the big monster is
coming after me like right now well this
helped me none no thanks
god damn Oh nope nope nope the mouse
jumps up the mouse jumps down the mouse
jumps in the pot and then he's drunk you
load if it is okay to carry on my
wayward son for the hell am I going to
loot I sure hope a big monster doesn't
pop out of nowhere
oh boy another chest piece pop it isn't
guarded by Buster well everything seems
good so far I don't think I need this
flashlight as much as I use it okay stop
cool what fire got started do I need to
be concerned about that
probably I hear the screech of that
monster in the distance but I don't know
if it's actually something I need to
concern myself with because right around
this corner there's gonna be a piece to
place
Kabu only need two more pieces Queen and
then the rook I'll get him just good I
played the hell out of chess with that
monkey ain't no way no one's gonna stop
me now right
I miss Kay I don't I want to see her
why won't came come to see me smashing I
spend all my time with the doctor now
the doctor is jealous of the love Kate
and I have for each other the doctor is
the one keeping Cain from me I'm sure of
it I miss Cain I want to see him no no
thank you I'm not gonna touch that with
a ten-foot pole I'm just gonna get my
chess pieces and get out and get my gold
that's the promised reward this game is
messed up by the way this game is
sincerely severely messed up right any
goodies yeah bad we have awesome bins
ooh
all right I'm glad this lighter has
unlimited fuel so I might be screwed to
some junctures I am getting a lot of
story in this particular set of
wandering the senator had an affliction
rashes upon welts that covered him from
the belly to scrotum him I was on a
medical visit on behalf of the crown for
America's new world of York Her
Majesty's service wanted to boast our
doctors could rival that of any American
the elderly politician had seen them all
the best these United States had to
offer what the hell era are we in
exactly because I was pretty sure
there's relatively modern here I'm not
quite familiar with the things that are
going on I slowed down a bit so I'm
going to just walk a gentle pace till I
get to where I need to go so it made me
loop through this again I don't know if
that means that I need to I'm being
punished but the only thing I can do is
keep wandering through the halls cuz
that place broad block oh this is just
gonna loop back and forth again isn't it
yeah blooped again okay there's got to
be something in here he's gotta be
something in one of these rooms that I
need or I just wanted to put me in a
corner so I could get killed by the
monster
okay zoom guys don't see a monster
anywhere do you
okay what's this
this looks slightly important anything
important dammit you got quiet I'd
rather on the orchestra back please
I don't like quiet do your breathing is
that my breathing okay
goddamn Eliza just gonna loop again what
am i doing around what do you want from
me sorry that was the wrong door
apparently it's locked
these are all locked up what am I
supposed to do oh these are well these
are just the cellblocks [ __ ] a duck
Jesus man
I'm gonna come in there i'ma beat the
crap out of you all Christmas I had no
chance the screams were coming from
another place why did that happen to me
Jesus Emily Johnson
hope y'all had a good heart attack out
of that do I still have the peace do I
did okay dying has no consequence good
to know
right back into the breach on small I
friends thrust Thunder tear that I
forget pool I forget it good wait why
don't I just come back to where wounds
oh when I was easy to find the arrogance
of the Eagle was in overlooking the
natural remedies from the east the
Chinese maybe Communists I assured him
after applying the self but their
natural remedies were the best he made
sure I kept call out about my practice
until the next few years I was his
personal aide until his boss had come
calling saying something about a new
opportunity to make the world a better
place
great it's just like what you're doing
I'm sure yay we can play chess I can get
my gold can have my gold please no oh
I'll just leave that fine
that music doesn't sound good then again
there's been many opportunities when the
music doesn't sound good and yet here we
are
but why so did I do something wrong or
some I need to do extra why is this the
way it is Oh blue people okay who does
something please why am i looping again
I found all the chess pieces there's
nothing else I need to find oh thank you
yes please send the monster to me I
definitely need a full dose of scythe to
the face pretty sure it had scythes as
weapons okay we're going down down is
good that was probably not good but I
said that before too and look how that
turned out I'm just deeper in the
nightmare than ever before so great
good great good good great great
goodness great goodness does befall me
if this was just gonna loop back to the
same place I don't know if there's a
purpose to this
you know he told me I would be going to
a new home where doctors with my talents
would be needed at first I thought of
Rwanda or Senegal even China little did
I know I was going to be staying here
only hidden from the world
great mile underground will some will
never run who cares about your plights
because you're kind of crazy where is he
I don't know if this guy's actually the
villain or not but he seems kind of
villainous all right either way I am all
out of time for this episode so we're
gonna continue this in the next one I
don't know if we're getting close to the
end I really don't know how long this
game is I underestimated how long it
would be and I'm still playing it but
hey it's actually a really cool game so
thank you everybody so much for watching
click the annotation for more videos
that I've done and as always I will see
you in the next just like a smaller
story I don't know what specific
Oh